en réalité j'ai dû
c'était comme obélix j'étais tombé dans
la marmite depuis bien longtemps
[Musique]
j'avais fait déjà des campagnes de mon
père j'avais suivi des campagnes
municipales j'avais suivi des campagnes
à la trinité-sur-mer j'avais rédigé des
enveloppes pour envoyer des tracts enfin
je veux dire c'était mon c'était mon
quotidien est presque j'avais même
résisté parce que il souhaitait me
me positionner comme candidate avant et
j'avais voulu attendre d'être
des travaux cas je pense que j'étais
déjà vocal a tout juste à peine et donc
votre choix votre choix à vous non non
c'est maintenant en réalité non pour
jacques c'est d'être candidate parce que
il me le demande mais je suis encore
dans une période où en fait je n'ai pas
envie de faire de la politique et j'ai
envie de faire tout sauf de la politique
c'est pour ça que je deviens avocat
d'ailleurs je devais avocat parce que je
ne veux pas faire de politique la
politique pour moi c'est l'horreur et je
le fais parce que personne ne veut aller
face à pons qui faisait une annonce 80 %
au premier tour où 85% au premier tour
et donc là pour le coup je rends service
mais j'ai pas du tout décidé de faire de
la politique
[Musique]